welcome welcome to your mom's house
Christina the gypsies so I was in a
Jacksonville Florida and I did some
morning press oh good you were in the
same hotel room that I had turds on the
ground well I wasn't yeah that's where
the the club the club was at the turds
on the ground sacred grounds were the
trench yeah loaded yes
and you're also returning the Cincinnati
will you be paying homage to the
Cincinnati fart yeah of course the
Renaissance Hotel in downtown Cincinnati
room was it 3:15 I think so yeah uh I
will I will go and I'll probably a few
flowers down I think we should call that
hotel and ask them if people are that's
a good idea
so Bailey if you guys have many people
with pilgrim pilgrimages pilgrims do
pilgrims come count 315 yeah let's see
this is from okay let's see it I'm so
used to Curtis being the one that can
dress this up and all right he's here to
make you laugh comedian Tom Segura aka
DJ dad mouth is in town
welcome to First Coast living thanks for
having me man First Coast living Oh
coast what's the first coast first coast
I guess is I don't know that's our
disabilities I don't know why it's the
first guys I mean I like I've been DJing
a lot Morgan doing stand-up so my focus
has been wrapping up to the stand-up
shows and then hitting some turntables
it's true it is it is what I'm all about
it is and I like that they feed you so
you're eating the entire interview I
requested it because they had a chef on
right before me
I love only do that and then I go bring
some of that food over here and then I
just ate what were you eating there
fruit they had like some type of yogurt
and then there was bacon over there - oh
yeah it's pretty good I like that you
wore the chain and the phone give a
shout out to Kim man
you are neighs and throat Zillah Zillah
ya said a friend do I want to hear the
story remember what time we're on no I
mean yeah she's a dallas-based
entertainer okay um she's gifted if you
have you know 500 bucks you can do it
right I was just told to stop for that
story time okay yep all right so your
second so fun it's so fun to do press
like this
oh yeah it's er Dale is there ridiculous
just I mean listen who's watching these
it's old ladies mm-hmm at home they're
not coming to the club yeah their
chances are it's not the same audience
and no hell no man nobody that watched
this came to my show not one it's
totally different Anya and I've learned
because for years they have you think
that like this is really important um
but it's fun to just go have fun let's
have fun in the morning show
chef James had prepared this stuff
earlier here I like the other the other
Karen oh yeah see that's the one with
the jello on there you got some health
we've got some bacon we did that chef
ooh chef James from public drag the most
fun this guy I know he's having a good
time he loves he was really fun lousy
and then afterwards the whole new hour
this weekend so really yeah it's a whole
new hour it's gonna be a good time and
then your wall hit the after-party and
get some fruit chef James here though
I'm like um I'm going to stop James now
going to Publix you know what
you should've popped ideas on a tweet
where the after-party is is that Chef
James house I love that they when I was
talking about chef James they yet it's
they cut to chef James well so your
beard looks so full it does it looks
great I'm not doing I'm not doing okay
you did good sensitive he made bacon to
chef James
that is so perfect that's
unintentionally perfect yeah
yeah that makes it look like a sketch
well right he was a shit
that was so so perfect on this part chef
James I didn't give a shit this is for
you that was great
tell he was beautiful juicy yummy sham
she's my wife
very very large I can forget always
gotta throw that in there huh yep you do
have a large sigh I know they're
enormous and they hang now christina
pazsitzky yep um she's my wife very very
large
tits resin there so hanging now since I
had this kid yeah god they look terrible
no no uh I like it was good that was
really good Jean it's fun so much fun um
and this next one uh I also appeared in
another morning show both full clips are
available on YouTube under your mom's
house podcast channel so if you go to
youtube.com slash your mom's house
podcast you can watch these in their
entirety and a bunch of other clips you
can also subscribe and these videos will
automatically its press right got to
prescribe it yeah you gotta force try
several doc do you look a little
different thanks for dressing up for us
well you know ah man
oh you know know why why you look a
little different thanks for dressing up
for us well you know I've been focusing
more on my DJ and so the comedy is kind
of like something on the side now I just
really it's all about the after post
some people believe it does this have
anything to do with your big
announcement
oh this was great so for people that
don't know when you do press they go hey
which we asked you so I had them ask I
go just to ask me about my big
announcement and that's why she said
that there and she doesn't know what
it's gonna be she just knows to ask I
say with your little outfit that you
have on a little LJ
yelled amore I thought maybe you know I
an athlete or some sort that's correct
well actually you know I'm also a sports
agent now and I recently I was just fun
to say Jalen Ramsey the new Jaguar he's
actually now client of mine so that was
just a good time there don't seem to be
having as much fun or not but I had a
say yeah if I could be critical of
myself yeah I realized afterwards that I
should have brought more energy to this
I stayed I stayed subdued and you know
it was like rehearsal before the the one
that I played first was a second of so
you had to get your legs yeah yeah yeah
so it was a but it was a good learning
lesson now I know that when I go do
these morning things go in with a lot of
energy yeah cuz they're all high energy
yeah they're always like hey yeah yeah
yes I'm a busy guy man so they
announcement yeah big announcement the
big announcement wanted to make is the
last year you know I came out as poly
and buy and now I'm proud to say that
I'm non-binary what is that what is that
yeah great was what is that is that she
was so so disappointed in every aspect
of my dad there's such a judgy mom like
ah okay and cut to commercial yo she
wanted to cut to commercial she texted
them afterwards to the people that the
girl that brought me and she showed me a
text she was that was awkward uh
hilarious well she's got a total mom
haircut she's got the mom cut to max got
is John and Kate yeah uh little vibe
yeah she went full full mum cut well uh
what why can't I find this we got to do
that thing man we got to do that thing
about about just getting the these
arranged in some way um let's see if
this is it here I'm proud to have come
out of this polyamorous and now I'm
excited to share that I'm bisexual I
like I like I love how friends I and now
I'm I came out as Polly and by
and now I'm proud to say that I'm
non-binary what is that line arey I
liked his language choice are you like
last year I was excited to get out as
special yeah proud to come out yeah it's
a very specific language yes
interesting um the great part here too
if you watch the video or if you're
watching with us here on YouTube you can
see in this next moment when I explain
very there's a reaction there any is
there more to it cuz I'm confused
oh yeah like so most people fall within
the male and female binary yeah
and then I'm non-binary I don't fall
into either one you know so like I'm
actually like fluid binary meaning that
depending on the moment I kind of go
between different genders interesting
like today I'm astral gender right now
which is a I'm a gender from outer space
as two hosts who couldn't find a door
yesterday thank you very action loss I'm
a gender from outer space as two hosts
who couldn't find it
yeah she's so so not having it not fun
not yesterday to get into a place we
only want it we are totally long there's
such nerds and they're also like this
just really went downhill yeah to them
this isn't this is the most fun thing
that's ever happened on this channel you
know Emily it was a pretty it's a pretty
big thing to come out as non-binary
you're the first we've encountered
really yeah so that is a big
announcement it's a big announcing that
on her show yeah I'm happy to share with
everybody you know so you know just if
you don't mind referring to me as they
done they they are gonna be at the
comedy zone tonight for what and then
finally well you can catch Tom on stage
all weekend at the comedy zone
not to throw Zilla they don't know who
that is for sure
haha oh shit anyways I'm so amazing I'm
really planning my next one now now I'm
asking um to do yeah I'm like I do some
more morning TV morning TVs horrible
this is gonna get you off the morning TV
circuit quicker than you just
complaining that really you actually
beer being proactive this is how you do
it yeah this is how you never have to do
morning press ever is just fuck it all
up I don't know what polyamorous meets